oh hi everyone and thanks for joining me
on this webinar I'm gonna do kind of a
quick overview of some of the new stuff
in deep liar 0.7 we'll start with kind
of a bunch of smaller stuff none of its
kind of particularly exciting by itself
but an aggregator that adds up to just
relieving a whole bunch of small pain
points and deep liar then I'll talk a
little bit about databases and then
finish off by talking about tidy eval
which is a new system for programming
and deep liar so there should be plenty
of time for questions I'll stop after
uke section and take you need that
particularly interesting to the whole
crowd okay so the first thing I wanted
to mention if you don't already know
about a deep layer has a website now
deep large tidy verse org it's that's a
great way if you want to see the
examples and the cards see the vignettes
and generally gonna an overview of the
package so it's like that's a great
place to start if there's anything you
want to know more about deep liar after
this we've now I also wanted to mention
briefly the tidy verse package I'm just
going to use if you haven't heard of a
tidy verse so the tiny verse package
just basically makes it easy get a bunch
of packages that work well together so
when you install it you it installs all
of the packages and the tidy verse and
then when you load it it loads the most
important packages so here I'm showing
you the development version which in
conjunction with development vision of
Studio gives you this pretty colorful
display telling you which packages are
loaded so you can see here I'm using the
development version of it gives you a
little bit of information a little bit
of session info so you can if you're
having problems you can have you know
your code works and your computer not
someone else's you can often track down
the difference to one of these issues
and then finally tells you what are the
functions that ID versus as master from
base our other packages so with
let's dive into some of the new stuff
and deep wire the first one is that
there's two new data sets that if you're
teaching be plier might be handy and
we'll be using these more and more on
the examples to illustrate more
sophisticated so the first one is the
Star Wars data set which contains a
bunch of information about the
characters from Star Wars which come
from the swappi the Star Wars API site
and one of the things that's different
about this data set compared to other
data sets and other packages is this
contains a few simple list columns so
for example you can look at this films
column and there tells you it's a list
column because each a person may have
appeared in more than one or I think I
think they've all appeared in more than
one but some of these other star wars
vehicles similar because someone might
have not sure would in any vehicle or
they might have traveled in more than
one vehicle hopefully so Star Wars some
fun data about the characters in the
Star Wars universe and contains some
list columns to practice your list
column skills on the other knee down a
set is this data set about us war are
storms in the Atlantic this contains a
whole bunch of data from the from
hopefully the documentation will tell me
from the NOAA Atlantic hurricane
database so there are 198 storms in here
going from 1975 to today we can do a
quick plot and you can see approximately
where they where they start out and
where they end so this data set has a
rich grouping data rich grouping data
structure rich gripping structure
because you're probably going to want to
group each storm and then do compute
various summary statistics on so great a
great dataset for practicing your group
by skills so 2news data sets there's a
handful of other data sets that you can
read about and the release notes or the
blog post that are just really simple
data
if you wanted to teach people basic join
functions or practicing yourself there's
one that new important verb and deep
wire called pull pull gives you a single
column so this has been a long long time
source of frustration for many deep lie
users if you use select and give it a
single variable name it's still going to
give you a table it's gonna give you a
table that just has a single column if
you use pole it is going to give you
that that single vector this is
basically equivalent to this code you
could do already using the dollar sign
but it works on database backends and
the other thing that sometimes handy is
you can use it to select columns by
their position the default you can also
see you can select from the front from
the left-hand side if you give it a
positive number or you can select from
the right-hand side
you get a negative number and indeed if
you don't give Paul anything that is the
default it's going to take the rightmost
column by default kind of under the
assumption that if you've just created
something and you probably want to take
a look at that so that's pole the new
data since those are kind of the biggest
of the small new things there's a bunch
of if we put a bunch of work into
improving the error messages so
hopefully if you do something by
accident that you didn't mean to you
should now get a better error message
from D player that tells you both where
the problem is a the column what it was
expecting and what you gave it which
should hopefully make any problems
easier to diagnose and debug we also put
a bunch of time into encoding support in
D player probably the most the case that
affected the most number of people was
if you use c JK Chinese Japanese or
Korean languages or datasets containing
those languages on Windows you basically
could not use D player without a huge
amount of pain so that should now all be
resolved and if you discover any
differently please let us know so we can
fix that we
I made some changes to make joined and
and similar functions behave better when
the columns your joining at different
encodings
I just wanted to still illustrate one
little example of this which which just
illustrate how painful and codings and
are can be because here I just created a
string it's a word a little I remember
my high school French correctly I mean
student and when you print these two
strings out they look at DeAnza go and
indeed if you ask indentical are they
the same it says yes I guess they are
the same but if you go and say well tell
me the binary representation of the
string using charter raw we can see that
they're actually different strings and
that's because they have a different
encoding so you can see X's and colons
utf-8 and oops and Y as encoded as
latin-1 so now D player should just kind
of handle this sort of this problem for
you automatically if you're using radar
and other packages in the title you
should always get UT if data as your
input generally that that's easier to
work with just stick with UTF a rather
than messing around with different with
different encoding so whatever your
encoding is on disk load that up convert
it to utf-8 and use that so again
finalize this to just this problem to
just go away behind the scenes without
me you having to do anything another
tiny little feature that's quite nice is
now that case case win function works
inside mutate maybe you have not seemed
case win before but it's a really useful
alternative to a whole bunch of nested
if else's so I'll show you a quick
little demo of using case win just a
simple case and then show what that
looks like now that it works inside
mutate so here I'm going to use case win
to implement the sort of infamous
fizzbuzz programming challenge and
basically in the fizzbuzz programming
challenge all you have to do
print out a victor of 50 or 100 numbers
but when that number is divisible by
five you need to print furs when it's
divisible by seven you need to print
bars and when it's divisible by five and
seven you need to print fizzbuzz in case
when allows you to express the spree
succinctly it says basically we use
these use the formula the toddler is
basically kind of an if/then so if it's
divisible by 35 then return fizzbuzz if
it's divisible by five then return fizz
if it's divisible by seven then between
bars otherwise for everything else this
is always true is always gonna be true
convert it to a character so case when
operates sequentially so as soon as the
first thing is true it's going to ignore
the rest so when we run this on my
victor one to five we solved this
fizzbuzz programming challenge one two
three four there's six bars eight nine
Thurs and so on a more realistic use is
to use it in the context of a data frame
it's really useful when you need to
recode variables so here I've just kind
of made a very well somewhat silly
example using the Star Wars noticing
where I want to categorize different the
different characters based on a
combination of their height and the
amass and their species so I'm saying if
the height is greater than 200
centimeters or their mass is greater
than 200 kilograms I'm going to say that
there are a large type if they are a joy
to say they're a robot type if are human
I'm gonna say they're a human type
otherwise it's a true means otherwise
I'll just mark them as other so winner
in this I get a new column called type
which succinctly expresses exactly how I
want to do that that transformation and
this is much easy and doing the kind of
equivalent set of if-else statements
which would look like two hundred mass
greater than two hundred in large
otherwise I need to do another
as with species equals droid and if
you've ever ridden any of these kind of
mr. the file statements yourself you
know this gets painful really really
quickly also a whole bunch of other bike
fixes mostly just little stuff but you
know whenever you had a bag no matter
how small it is it's always frustrating
to deal but so that's kind of a summary
of there's a few of the my my most
favorite small features in deep well
I'll take a quick look at the questions
just to see if anything has come up I
see someone has asked about if it is not
for the memory which we're going to talk
about next
oh and if you haven't seen this this
operator before but seeing the scene
this is this is not a deep liar thing
this is a bass our thing this is the
modulo operator so this expression
basically means if it's divisible by 35
with remainder zero and yes case when
works with all of the deep layer to
summarize mutate and so on if you're
going to use case although if you're
gonna use case we in with samurai I
guess case win works with summarize for
some definition of work it's basically a
vectorized function which means you it
gives you the same number of outputs as
the same number inputs as the number of
inputs which means it's most fitting to
work with mutate with somewhere the
summary functions you didn't you want a
function that takes multiple values
written to a single value so case when
you could probably make it work with
worth summarize but typically you'd need
to do you know you'd need to use some
kind of summary function around the
outside and this that doesn't make any
sense in this case but maybe you could
say paste it when you supply to collapse
argument to paste that becomes a summary
function because it's going to take in
strings and return a single string
okay so next I wanted to talk about the
new database support in deep layer or
the improve database support and deep
layer again if you want to learn more
about this the best place is the website
DB plier so DB plier is the package that
now provides all the database related
functionality in deep layer by and large
you will not need to know about this
package you will generally not need to
attach this package but so deep I will
load that for you you will need to
install it and you'll need to know that
this is where their code is if you need
to get help so the biggest change in
this version our DB plier is in this
version of deep ly and the matching
version of DB plier is that there's much
much better integration with the DB I
package now so the DB I package is a
uniform interface to many many many
different databases so to use the DB I
package you always pair it with a
database specific R package so for
example I am going to create a
connection to a database so to create a
connection to a database you use the DB
connect function from the DB I package
and the first argument to that net
function is the the database driver or
the R package that provides the database
connection so here I am going to connect
to it a sequel Lite database which is
provided by the sequel Lite package if
you haven't heard of sequel Lite before
this is a great this is a fantastic
place to start with databases because
the database is actually included in the
sequel Lite and the our sequel Lite
package so most database systems you've
got like a database server which can be
a pain to sit up and get running with
sequel Lite their database they keep
bundled in the package for you so it's
really really easy to get up and going
and I'm gonna cheat even further I'm
gonna make this even easier to get up
and going with and I'm gonna use a
temporary in-memory database so I have a
connection to this database and you can
use DVI to connect all sorts of packages
sequel Lite my sequel Postgres and then
I'll talk a little bit a little bit
later about some of the
enterprise databases that we're working
to build support for our studio as well
so going to connect to their database
and now I am going to use one of the dbi
functions
DBI right table to copy a data frame to
that data place and so what's new in
this version is basically the seamless
interaction between d bi which is a very
low-level function that allows you to
execute sequel queries directly if you
know sequel and d bi and apply which is
a much higher level interface which will
write those sequel queries for you
so now I can say create a new table from
this connection I'm going to call this
the database table is called empty cars
and I'm going to call this our object
empty cars to just because just to avoid
confusion with the other previous Indy
cars data frame so they put this out
you'll see that this is now a remote
table it's a table in a database and in
fact in that database is a sequel Lite
data and the neat thing about using
deeply with a database is that deeply I
would generate the sequel for you and
there's been a bunch of improvements to
the sequel generation in this version
one of the really nice improvement is
optimizer that was contributed by H
villain which reduces a lot of the sub
queries a deep fly added previously so
let's take it a little example I'm going
to take this empty cars to data set I'm
going to filter it I'm going to select
some variables and then I'm owning a
look at the top 10 and if I was going to
run the array just run that run this
card what deep liar does behind the
scenes is generate the sequel query
seems that to the database the database
does all the work and then return some
results if you want to see the query
that deep layers generating you can use
the show query function and you can see
here this queries there's probably
pretty similar to what you'd write by
hand we're going to select these
variables from this data from this table
where this condition is true and I'm
going to limit the results to at most to
you now in the previous version of deep
layer this would have generated
at least you know three sub-queries
which in some databases can degrade
performance and definitely makes it hard
harder to understand what the player is
doing when it generates at the sequel
for you we've also added more support
for type coercion so if you need to
change the type of a variable in the
database to a character or a victor or
an interview you can use the the are
functions you're familiar with and those
are automatically being converted behind
the scenes to the appropriate sequel so
here you can see I'm using transmute if
you haven't heard of transmute before
it's a variant of mutate that just only
keeps the variables you specify it
doesn't keep on the other variable so
you can see what this generates oops
forgot the pipe you can see what this
generates this isn't quite as optimal
sequel but you can see that it's
generating this this cast which is how
you change the type of a variable in
sequel again and here I used pull as
well just to pull down that variable
from their query out of the database
another thing that's changed in the the
latest version of D player is that
there's an annoying bug whenever you're
using in now this J always generates the
correct sequel previously we would
forget to put the parentheses in the
year which is valid our code but not
policy crooked so baked in to DB apply
this translation support for the major
open source databases sequel Lite my
sequel and PostgreSQL we are working to
add more support for commercial
databases so this version also includes
translation support for MS Microsoft
sequel server
Apache Impala and how Apache hive when
you use them through the ODBC package
it's the ODBC package as another package
we've been working on recently
it is a dbi compliant back in for DBC
databases so
this makers ODBC is a very popular
standard for connecting to databases
this makes it very very easy to connect
to a whole bunch of commercial databases
that are not that do not have the best
support and are right now so this is
something we're working on hard at our
studio at the moment you'll hear more
from us in the near future but we want
to connect into any database we want to
make it as easy as possible to get your
data from wherever it is with its sequel
server whether it's Oracle whether it's
post-first with its redshift to get that
data from wherever it lives inside your
organization and our and we've been
working on a whole set of whole there's
like 10 packages involved in various
ways at the moment we'll be display
we'll be sharing that vision with you
there's a whole bunch of other small
improvements the sequel translation
again just little things if they
affected you before there'll be much
less pain now than it was previously but
the other big thing that a lot of people
have been clamoring for is support for
schemas so I'm just going to do a little
demonstration of that I'm going to
create another database another sequel
Lite database and I'm going to attach it
this is the way that sequel Lite allows
you to work with multiple schemas sequel
IDEs kind of a very small database
doesn't they're like amazing schema
support but at least it allows you to
demonstrate the feature I'm going to
create two tables called both called D
if one is the going to be the IRS data
frame and one is gonna be the EMT cars
data frame and I'm gonna put these in
different schemas so now DB player has
this new function called in schema which
allows you to be specific about what
schema you want to look for the table
and so here this is saying look and the
auxilary schema for a table names d if
and we do that what you can see here
basically is that we refer to this we
can now see explicit about what schemer
we want to get our table for so if you
don't use if you don't use schemas you
know this does not affect you at all but
many big corporate databases
is schemas extensively and this should
make you all your life much much easier
so this is a quick overview of the new
database features in deep layer let's
look for a few questions so one question
is if his plans to support and they use
the bit 64 package to support 64-bit
integers that's not going to happen at
the DB plier level but that's that's
work that's in progress on the the dbi
package and unfortunately it needs work
and all of the individual database
backends that's something that we're I
think we've added in the progress of the
process of adding to the DVI
specification and they're also kind of
slowly roll out to the various database
backends over the over the next 12
months and I'm pretty sure we've added
that support into the ODBC package a few
other questions about specific databases
yes we're going to add support for
Oracle yes we will add specific redshift
support the the translation and general
is it's obvious you've documented more
on the DB prior website it works best
for the types of simple expressions that
you do when you are typically filtering
and summarizing and mutating your data
this is not a trends you can't just run
any arbitrary R code on the database
obviously there's no way to run like a
linear model on the database or
generalized additive model on the
database the database just don't have
support for that so the goal with a
sequel translation in deep liar DB
player is to allow you to kind of
iterate quickly typically you know there
are a very large number of kind of big
data problems with a key problem it's
just getting the right small data and
you need to go to iterate quickly
between the daygame and getting the
right data and are and rather than
having the constants constantly context
switch between deep liar and so our code
and sequel code you can focus on just
writing our code and deep I will take
care
of the writing the sequel for you so
this is a and practice is the most
people I've talked to that the
translation just works if it doesn't
work you can always write the sequel
code yourself but for the type of simple
stuff that you're typically doing when
like summarizing or subset the
translation is really really good
okay so let's finish off by talking
about tidy eval which is kind of the the
biggest and most complicated a new
feature in deep lie and just before I
sort of talk about exactly what this is
I want to like illustrate the problem
that we're trying to solve and so here
I've got a little table and I'm doing
some data analysis with it and I'm
basically each of these three clumps of
code I am doing the same summary but
with a different group and to do this
with D play you might be copying and
pasting your code and that's great I
think a rule of thumb is it's fine to
kind of copy and paste up to like three
times but as soon as you go beyond there
it's worth the investment to write a
function and that's because often you
know the thing that you're doing is
changes if you discover a bug and if
you've copied and pasted that code
everywhere tracking down every single
instance of that file can be really
painful so it's a really good idea to
turn repeated code that you've created
by copying and pasting into a function
but this is hard because deep layer
lacks a property called referential
transparency so let me try and just
describe this quickly so basically and
I've created two simple functions one
that just multiplies it and put my ten
and one that adds 10 and normally when
you're writing functions in R you can
extract out kind of a sub extrude
expression or part of that function
called and assign it to a variable and
that that doesn't matter you can do that
as much as you like and you always get
the same result that's what's called
referential transparency it doesn't you
can create
two variables and it doesn't change how
the expression was computed but this
doesn't work with deep liar because you
can't going to pull out that let that
expression you can't pull out this
repeated code there's G one this G 2 and
just GG 3 you can't assign that to a
variable because there is no objects
called that because inside the deep
layer expressions to make your data
analysis your data manipulation is fast
and fluid as possible and here this
variable refers to a variable inside the
data file so this is one of the features
of our called as sometimes called
non-standard evaluation where we're
taking this expression and we're
evaluating it in the special way and
this is really great because it allows
you to save so much typing you know
you're not constantly having to type the
data the name of the data frame again
and again and again and your expressions
but the downside of this this
implicitness is that it's harder the
program and so in this version of deep
lie we have a new system called tidy
eval which is basically a new framework
for programming with dir dealing with
this type of problem in general and so
you know if you have a count if you
encounter this problem you might say
well I can't assign it to I can't assign
the be a variable name maybe I could try
putting that inside a string and and
that still doesn't work because it's
looking for a column called grouped bar
it's not looking inside that variable to
find it G - so to solve this problem we
have a new data structure called a
closure which you can create with the
quo function so this basically kind of
captures the expression so this is what
deep layer is all about it's about
capturing what you want and evaluating
it at a different time so so you know
when you do this in deep lie it's about
capturing this expression and evaluating
in a different context and the context
we don't have to be don't ever say when
every which data frame every variable
comes with or in the case of when you're
all talking about a database it's
actually doesn't even get evaluated by
our it gets in value by the database
much much later on so now we can use
this quo function to kind of capture
this variable so we're saying we don't
want we want to use this variable G one
later on now unfortunately that still
doesn't work with goodbye so what we
need is some way to kind of unquote this
variable we just said don't don't take
this valuable don't take this input
literally look inside this variable and
see what it means and so we now have
this unquoted
tool bang bang and so what this tells D
plier to do is don't just say don't look
at group but literally look at what's
inside group file and evaluate that and
so this gives us the ability to program
with D ply we can now create functions
where you can write functions that work
like de playa does we can even take this
further you can not only do the grouping
variables but you can use this an every
single every single function and apply
with a summarized or mutate or meaning
or whatever so this I am like a hundred
percent confident that the theory behind
this is is correct and robust and works
like a hundred percent of time not just
ninety-five percent of time we are still
working to like try and explain it in a
way that that you can understand this is
basically it's sort of a similar level
of complexity to learning how to write
functions so if my explanation right now
just lift you reeling and Confused do
not blame yourself that is my fault that
I do not know a good way of explaining
that yet that yet but we are working on
that you can always see kind of our
latest if it's on the D player website
there is an article about programming
with deep liar that explains the problem
and much more depth and we will keep
rewriting that until we are confident
that we just we have figured out a good
way to explain
what's going on here in a way that you
can understand and then deploy in your
own code so that that's all I had to
talk about let's take a look at a few
few questions again I'm just going to
kind of skim through and if anyone else
from studio wants to like raise any
questions to me please do so but I'll
just take a little quick look these
questions and see what what might be of
interest broadly so one question is
what's the difference between this new
system and the previous system which
used underscores after function names
looked more like inverses used functions
and it used formulas and basically the
problem with the old system is that
there was no easy way to write code like
this you'd have to do something and I
understand even they think you have to
write like inter and then you have to do
something like the thing like a summary
so basically the the previous system of
nonsense evaluation was extremely
constrained and it didn't actually help
you solve the problems that you that you
really needed to solve so again this new
system that's a little bit more
complicated it's going to take a little
bit more work to understand what's going
on but I think that investing the time
and that is really going to pay off
because it allows you to do more things
in deep layer and we're going to be
rolling out the system everywhere and
the tiny verse so hopefully in the next
month or so you'll be able to use the
same system and tidy R and by this the
end of the year you'll be able to use
the same system in ggplot2 so again it's
an investment it's gonna take a little
bit of time to get your head around it
but once you do you're gonna be using
it's gonna make programming with all of
these kind of slightly magical functions
designed for data analysis much much
easier yes if someone pointed out that
quo and bang bang are kind of somewhat
equivalent to be quote an eval yes that
is absolutely correct although be quote
only handles the expression not the
Associated environment which leads to
several bugs that again sort of be quote
kind of works like no 95 percent of the
time which makes the 5% of the time it
doesn't work really really frustrating
to debug we've tried to move that pain
kind of upfront with tidy eval it's
gonna be a little bit more payable to
learn it but once you've learned it this
should be fast food you are unpleasant
surprises down the end bunch of
questions are about quo and in quo yes a
lot of you spotted that I used quo in my
example up here but then I used in quo
inside the function but the difference
here is a little bit subtle that quo
basically always gives you its input
back so if I used quo inside this
function it's always going to use it's
always gonna put group VAR but here I
don't actually want group var I want the
value in the group via variable I want
to kind of go one level up to see what's
inside that expression and that's what
encoder does rather than so in quo kept
is exactly what's inside the parenthesis
in choir use inside a function it looks
at that argument and see what expression
was associated with that expression a
couple of people are asked about where
the case win translates to sequel
queries that is a very good question
that I will have to look at the source
code answer it was definitely inspired
by it looks like we do not currently
have a translation for it but case tween
was inspired by the case win function in
in sequel
I'm just going to quickly file an issue
so I don't forget to add a sequel
translation for pace win and so we'll
make sure that happens in that and the
next version seeing lots of questions
about encoding basically they are it
kind of don't want to answer all of them
here because like fairly specific but if
you have any questions do please read
this programming article which should
hopefully answer your questions if it
does not please let me know you can
shoot me an email or send an email to
the manipulator programming list and
we'll work but basically looking through
the questions if you did ask a question
about this the answer is yes it is
possible it is similar to it's kind of
like a macro variables in sass although
it's those are just kind of work on the
base of text substitution this as much
this is much more robust and works in a
much wider range of situations